so it's about five o'clock in the
evening now Jacob myself have had
nothing to do for about three hours went
to a gun store checked out some
silencers and stuff and realized we
couldn't buy them we have no idea how
we're going to get back to the hotel
it's probably like ten miles away
man that is Wendy so by now you might
have seen us throwing a computer off of
the bridge and wondered why would we do
such a thing
well here's why
Sam Nikko and Jake are all out of the
office they're at Sundance right now
that leaves us to basically do
absolutely nothing in the studio we
didn't actually throw off a working
computer we would get fired for that
Carmichael has a dead computer behind
the camera here he was like hey this
computer's been dead for a while it
caught fire playing Tomb Raider once
because it was just so hot because it
was just so hot first we're gonna paint
it black the idea is to make it look
like our other main computers so we just
got out of the movie it's stuck
basically is really slow and there's
really nothing good about it
all I gotta say is it as well shot well
acted fully written poorly edited I was
slow I didn't really know where it was
going at all and now we are gonna do
better things we're gonna hang out with
Sean Duras he's taking them to a space
station I have a space station my
basement
it'll feel like I'm coming home give
Rainbow six on there no no
yeah but not go Shenzi that way you
gotta talk with Monaco Minako is great
yeah I don't have revenue six even
Ranbir do you that lens man here's the
sketchiest part there's a hole in the
fence here that's fine and all but we
got to cross the live train tracks so
fortunately fortunately trains are not
that fast
so are you serious what why didn't you
just ball yeah so there is a guy
standing in the exact spot I was hoping
to throw the computer kind of want to
warn him that we're gonna throw computer
off the bridge computer should
definitely shatter
sweet sounds great all right now let's
let's go clean it up Tyler alert same
thing also we're gonna have a sleepover
and go skiing Twitter lumber party sorry
I'm a supreme of slumber party that go
story pretty good so scary we watch
rated our movies and then we go skiing
slash snowboarding tomorrow we're
actually going back and I think we're
gonna be able to go back country riding
which is gonna be fun like have a cat
take us up never done backcountry riding
before three Sam's like fifth time
skiing yeah I don't serious it'll be fun
take two black diamonds get them
tattooed on your neck and that's the
hard cornice of this let's see a sham
braces like I've been toying with this
idea for all my daily vlogs to just
upload a thumbnail of minecraft gameplay
for all of them anything that work
forbids yes like some little kid clicks
on it and also he's just watching me
hang out with my wife and me and her
dogs is like what